así que está muy buenos días de hecho la
academia siempre se haya mostrado muy
reticente a que las películas que se
habían exhibido exclusivamente a través
de esas plataformas como juliette view o
netflix no pudieran optar a los premios
oscar pero la irrupción de la pandemia
ha ayudado a que esas películas sí que
pudieran optar en esta edición número 93
de los premios oscar pero en esta
ceremonia también se puso de manifiesto
la grave crisis que hay con las salas de
cine en este país hay más de 33 mil
repartidas por todo eeuu y de hecho el
sector ha dicho que a mediados de este
año a aquellas cadenas que han podido
sobrevivir a lo largo de estos meses de
pandemia podrían echar el cierre
definitivo si la cosa no mejora de hecho
la actriz francés mcdormand cuando
recogió la estatuilla a la mejor
película porno matt lamb hizo ese
alegato a ir al cine diciendo que en la
gente fuera a ver esa película en la
pantalla más grande posible pero esa
ceremonia de los premios oscar también
fue marcada
la crisis sanitaria se pusieron en
medidas protocolos sanitarios para
evitar los focos de infección a pesar de
que la organización quería mostrar un
ambiente de completa normalidad se
prohibieron las intervenciones por
videoconferencia y se permitió que la
gente que estuviera sin mascarilla
durante la gala esos y de todos los
asistentes tuvieron que hacerse la
prueba de el coronavirus antes de entrar
al recinto ahora anthony vimos que
claudia o la directora china
estadounidense se llevó el oscar a mejor
dirección por no más lana pero que otras
muestras de diversidad tuvo la ceremonia
si más allá de los protocolos sanitarios
que tuvo esta ceremonia la gala estuvo
marcada por la diversidad y por la
inclusión de afroamericanos son mujeres
y también extranjeros en esta ceremonia
de los premios oscar tomatlán que partía
como la clara favorita en todas las
quinielas se llevó tres estatuillas a la
mejor película a la mejor dirección y
también a la mejor actriz de hecho lo es
ya o fue la directora de tomatlán que se
llevó esa estatuilla se convirtió en la
primera mujer asiática en ganar un
premio oscar y en la segunda de toda la
historia en ganar esa estatuilla lo que
pone de manifiesto que en las 93
ediciones de los premios oscar sólo dos
mujeres han ganado un premio oscar en
esta categoría
anthony gracias por toda la información